[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome to the
show good monday morning
[Music]
how are you how are you this morning
we are going going this morning
welcome welcome to the tony michaels
podcast had just a little bit of
technical difficulties there but we are
working through it
we are gonna have a great show today we
have rachel bitkoffer again on the show
rachel how are you in the green room are
you over there are you good
okay good she's good to go fantastic
we're gonna talk about uh legitimate
political discourse today with rachel
the other thing that we're gonna do
today
uh with the uh
after after we we get done uh railing on
what what they want to refer to as
legitimate political discourses me and
gabe are gonna talk about a little bit
just a little bit just a little bit
about
uh the joe
rogan spotify uh can you say the n word
discourse andrew gang
the rock enters the chat so we're gonna
we're gonna go through all of that i
think even whitney cummings had some
statements today
midas touch has been accused of
orchestrating
you know with the cabal to make sure
that um they take down joe rogan
they even the mizellas brothers even
debated uh dave portnoy i don't know if
you can know that [ __ ] alpha cuck but
um they they debated
portnoy last night uh live on youtube so
maybe we'll get into that a bit as well
uh so hey barstool prez you're welcome
to come on my [ __ ] show and debate me
too as well portnoy if you think you got
the the nuts to do that let's like come
on over here and uh you'll you'll get it
you'll get an argument from me uh we got
a lot of people um this morning hi robin
how are you
good morning good morning good morning
good morning yoda
happy [ __ ] monday he says it's
ready to start this week ready to stay
pissed ready to stay pissed have some
strategic outrage i think i think
rachel's gonna give us some strategic
outrage this morning about the
legitimate political discourse i don't
know if you guys seen uh but the
republican parties are is eating
themselves i guess when you are the [ __ ]
sandwich you eat the [ __ ] sandwich
sometimes so um this morning we're going
to talk about how the republican party
is getting in complete disarray
it it is clear now where their wedge is
um and their wedges that they suck and
it sucks to suck so let's let's go after
them today you know let's not waste any
time let's let's just bring let's bring
rachel and rachel how are you
i'm doing tony it's it's monday woo
another week to save democracy we're
getting audio i'm not getting audio here
no
there we go there we go now i can hear
you there we go all right i was sorry
about that we had audio yes yes well my
my headphones weren't weren't operating
how are you this morning it's full of
monday and happy [ __ ] monday morning
dude yeah mondays suck right right right
so so over the weekend we saw
the republican party clearly clearly
they're in disarray clearly they're
broken uh clearly they can't decide what
type of fascism um you know there's a
lot of people that they love fascism
over there they're just not exactly sure
exactly what type so they call it they
called it what did they call it what did
they call it
i'm sorry
a legitimate political discourse
yeah yeah that's what they called it
that's what they call it so they think
they think january 6 you know that's
just that's just ordinary protesting
right it's just like just discourse so
explain to us why they why they are
messaging it this way and explain to us
why this is horrible for them and why
and how we can take advantage of it yeah
well you know tony when i enter into a
debate i always bring with me a few
cans of bear spray
you know and then beat my opponent in
the head with uh flagpoles and stuff you
know yeah right i mean yeah that's that
sounds legitimate it sounds like
political it sounds political and it
also sounds you know like discourse
right
we're gonna see them go to court and
argue that this is protected first
amendment speech to beat the cops with a
mega flag
right right well you know that you know
the great part is is they were beating
they were beating them with a flag
that's like blue lives matter right oh
yes oh yeah that's really
you're not gonna see any of that till
fall because i'm gonna [ __ ] hammer
them
where they don't have time to react and
they have to react in campaign time you
know what i mean
so like you get to see [ __ ] but not the
best [ __ ] yeah well right right and yet
the other crazy part is is that
you know here we are it's a year past
january 6th right they have two
republicans that are on the select
committee that are that are you know
tethered to some kind of reality
tethered to some kind of truth
and in in their attempt to de-legitimize
those two people because that's
literally what they're trying to do
is de-legitimize anything that adam
kinzinger or liz janey says right like
that's their whole attempt here
it it really isn't to censure them or or
i mean it is to punish them but
ultimately adam kinsinger's not
re-running so there's no punishing him
at this point liz cheney is gonna run in
wyoming regardless what they want yes i
mean and we're going to make damn sure
that she is financed
right and that she gets to go out there
and make that case and let me tell you
why we want people to do that right
because it's one thing for you and i to
sit here and [ __ ] about legitimate
political discourse
but it is the value of having an in like
somebody in the ca in the tent even if
they don't you're trying to kick them
out um
of being able to clarion call and pull
through all the [ __ ] and say no not
partisan at all right that's it's super
it's super value so valuable so yes you
know cheney is a die hard die in the
wool conservatives and honestly we
should be thanking god for that because
like the federalist society and these
constitutionalists are supposed to give
a [ __ ] about the constitution and they
all abandoned it right right so when we
look at a very few very small bucket of
people who were ideologues kinzinger is
not an ideologue right liz cheney is and
and if she was not
deeply committed to the american
experiment in terms of its you know
democratic small r republican principles
then she would not have blown up her
political career to do that right so
well you know i think one of the most
significant um
symbols from
the the old guard republican party is is
on january 6 this year when they
commemorated the one year anniversary of
the violence at the capitol and the only
republican standing in the chamber
you know commemorating the violence and
and you know respecting the lives of the
people who lost their lives that day the
law enforcement jesus christ is the law
and order party right
the only one was liz cheney and i think
the most significant part about it not
that she was standing there but dick
cheney darth vader himself
flew from wyoming to stand there on the
floor with her and to basically send a
signal to the republican party that hey
hey i'm still here and i am i am telling
you that what she is doing is what we
need to do like he was sending that
signal and and i think that is a
significant um symbol inside the
republican party and i believe that
that's what the rnc and trump want to do
is try to delegitimize you know this is
what this is the [ __ ] trump playbook
right right this is this is how they do
it they delegitimize their enemy they
delegitimize and they try to
delegitimize anything they say that's
the hunter biden laptop [ __ ] and all
that garbage you know they to try to try
to drag they're a political opponent as
if they don't know what they're talking
about or you know whatever and i think
that's that's the liz cheney part of it
but
the most important significant thing for
us as the left right and our argument
going forward
is they really stepped in it in a couple
different ways because they're like oh
it was political or legitimate political
discourse well if it was and it was
antifa and black lives matter and the
fbi
well then what are you bitching about
right like like you can't they have they
want to have it so many ways so how do
we how do we how do we make sure we have
that strategic outrage to break up that
that well i mean it's hypocrisy but how
do we drive wedges in between their
message because their messaging is all
over the map at this point yeah well i
mean here's the thing you don't do is
you don't you don't develop a plan
that's responsive right so like here's
the thing i was already gonna do this in
some iteration but now they've handed me
a phrase like to fund the police
and i'm gonna [ __ ] weaponize the
living [ __ ] out of that phrase tony and
my ultimate goal now i mean my goal was
to to somehow and i tell people when
they ask me what i do i'm like oh i i've
got to try to get america to panic
before there's really obvious reasons to
panic because if we don't do it
preemptively then we're going to hit
that spot and then it's really late and
that's what we know from all of the
civilizations that have ever failed
other than you know barbarians at the
gate that's how they do it when failure
comes internally it's because there's
massive signs of serious serious issue
and because of status quo by it bias
which i even have i mean i drive around
oregon i look at i go shopping and i'm
like how in the hell are we gonna get
you know what i mean so like that kind
of thinking prevents action in time and
so we have to panic people preemptively
and i was going to
you know i'm advocating with the with
democrats you know from the official
democrats all the way down
you have no choice in a midterm cycle
the midterms could be about you unless
you make it about them and they've
handed you
like this perfect condition because
them means fascism lawless right
disorder autocracy like that you can't
ask for a better [ __ ] wedge as long
as you personalize it for voters and
it's not abstract you know so people
talk about oh we should we can't talk
about democracy it's too abstract then
yeah well you know what you do is you
make it personal right there's lots of
ways to first i mean you can make
curriculum in k through 12 a completely
fake manufactured scandal crt because
it's not even real and then use that
turn that into a a buzzword that
everybody knows right so you have to
first increase salience and then you
increase a strategic outrage with it by
making one woman sit there and ring her
hands about her daughter being exposed
exposed to black porn in school right
like you don't
make it about the abstract because
unfortunately for us like 15 percent of
the public thinks about others a lot and
that's it and that leaves 85
of people with different values than
progressives okay so like speaking our
values is fine and [ __ ] danny but the
values i want to speak are the values
that the voters are going to vote either
decide to show up to vote or vote for
the opponent those are the values i'm
concerned with and their values are
pretty much centered around themselves
their family their community so you
really need to make that fear palpable
and real to them
well you know
and sometimes i believe it's going after
their message that that you know and
turning their message around on them
that i i think that's
why some of my audience likes how i say
things is because i i take their
argument and i turn it you know in the
opposite direction
for instance like the price of gas the
price of chicken the price of milk what
you say is is do you think milk
you're going to worry about the price of
milk now but the price of milk when
fascism takes over you think you're
going to even get milk
what what what on earth makes you think
that they won't choose who gets the milk
like they're already choosing who gets
what and that's what they want to do so
you're worried about the price of milk
now but there won't be a worry about the
price of milk you'll you won't be able
to get milk because they'll be choosing
who gets it and who doesn't that's
exactly right and you might be loyal
dude
right right so
and we've talked about this we did an
interview yesterday and we'll be playing
it this week i believe and we talk about
that in the interview and it's just like
you know with fascism you don't have
your church that you have you don't have
your school that you have you don't have
your community and i was talking with
someone yesterday and i said the the
communities that are going to be
affected by fascism first isn't the
communities that you think it's the
communities that that are going along to
get along now that will be affected the
most because what they'll do is they'll
look for the dissenters in the most
loyal parts of the country right and
that's that's what fascism does because
they're not going to bust into these big
cities where there's a huge diverse
population and start busting up the big
cities they're going to start small and
they're going to start their splashes
and small and they're going to come
where you're where you're going along to
get along and they've already started
that tony right i mean that's what we
have right now right coming out of 14 i
mean this is alec the american
legislative exchange council an
organization that's been in operation
now for you know 40 years and the
democrats still haven't bothered to even
build something that matches it on the
other side of what alec has evolved to
do
well and do it [ __ ] really well and
really efficiently is right model we
call model legislation so stand your
ground that was an alec bill and then it
got put out to 20 25 republican states
you know pre-written and pre-designed
right so we're not in the legislature
coming up with this [ __ ] right it's one
thing and they've already on team
fascism they're using wherever they have
control of state government even in
places that are extraordinarily blue
like virginia to use you know their
power to wipe out the curriculum to put
in uh gop snitch lines narc lines so
that people can knock on their teachers
who dare teach the truth about slavery
in the south right uh so you know the
fascism isn't it is true that most
likely an outcome is going to be a slow
decline of of democracy right what we
see in hong kong and in hungary and
things like that right it's not you know
the idea that we're going to see a big
flashlight event isn't isn't impossible
either right right the more likely
outcome and and this is the trajectory
that ronna mcdaniel the uh rnc chairs is
hoping for is that they'll win elections
this time largely democratically guys
the midterm effect is on their side
nobody knows that they're the party of
legitimate political discourse as of
today lacking 50 million dollars they're
never going to know that message because
right now that's not the message the
democrats intend to run
and we really have the very short window
of time to convince people that if
republicans take power legitimately
they're going to do what the nazis did
then use that power to consolidate it
permanently right
democratically and then they take power
and that's we're setting them up
perfectly in this midterm cycle
you know the the structure is setting
them up very very well to achieve that
so do we do we talk to the people who
already know that this isn't legitimate
political discourse or what do we or do
we message to the people out there who
actually went to the polls and voted uh
against trump and i i mean i think 81
million people voted um
cast their ballot for biden but i don't
think 81 million people voted for biden
specifically so how do we find because i
i think you know i don't know how many
millions of voters it is inside that 81
but how do we find the 81 million people
to tell them that the republican party
thinks that january 6 was legitimate
political discourse because they're
worried about deflategate they're
worried about tom brady retiring right
yeah so here's some good news tony is
that we have all that tactical
infrastructure in place it's just not
strategically organized to accomplish
that goal and with the messaging stuff
right that you know
coming in and and i i mean what i'm
teaching in messaging is so
different framed in the brain that i you
know when i work with the i do we do the
creative right but we have to put we
have to have executors and we we we're
teaching people who've been making ads
for a long time or whatever and copy
like this is yeah but this is how you
talk in a whole different way right
because everything on the left no matter
if it comes out from one group or the
other or done by the same consultant
world and that consultant world
it's a system that's not it's not
designed like the stuff i'm talking
about right it's not operating it's not
operating on their level to win the
fight not a referendum message it's not
a it's collective and not personal it's
in every way ineffectual and it was
ineffectual when we were winning in 2017
18 19 and 20 which is what i was telling
people we're going to [ __ ] win
regardless of the strategy right now
because they suck so bad yeah because
well because this is a vote this is like
the people are going to surge to the
polls
unstimulated right
they're going to have to [ __ ] be
unstimulated by us because we don't
stimulate okay
but luckily for us like that's gonna get
done for us
but i and i've always said this as soon
as trump is gone or power switches back
to the democrats strategy we will live
and die by it and this time i mean
literally
right
it is knocking at our door and we said
this before fascism is here speaking of
political heads i i found one on the
internet i don't know maybe maybe you've
seen it before here um let's let's let's
see if we can let's see if we can pull
this up here um it says it it's by um
you might know this person
rachel bittikov says legitimate
political discourse new ad legitimate
political discourse republicans are
declaring war on the soul of america uh
you don't you know who this is from i i
can't i can't tell yeah i've never heard
of those people but boy do they have
nuts
what let's let's
you want to watch this video let's see
let's see what it says
directly after troubleshooting
[ __ ]
can you see
what's so proud
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and bright stars
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
break
[Music]
get those [ __ ] rachel get those
[ __ ] now here's the thing right
so you gotta understand like that that's
for twitter it's
from twitter is willing to sit for two
minutes right right and like my concern
with outsourcing i always say my stuff
is simple simple but not simplistic and
my concern with not having personal
control over how something like that
message gets distributed is that no
one's going to look at [ __ ] anything
that's longer than 15 30 right right so
like that ad is a really powerful ad and
it might be um editable into a shorter
content because the voice is so nice and
so haunting right right just wanting
video but at the end of the day when you
want to hit those 81 million people tony
about 30 percent of them are what we
call marginal turnout like and they're
and they're not democrats right these
are the ones i was just talking about
earlier that that that voted against
trump is what you're yeah well they
don't even know about midterms like so
so the gop long ago was like okay we've
got a [ __ ] surge in decline problem
between midterms they figured that out
in
2006 when they got out voted right right
and so like then they were like well you
know let's tweak the system and make
sure that we can hit
turn out cycle the cycle right and like
in 18 i
knew the house was going to be a huge
surge and a lot of it was just that the
lines were 10 years old and they had not
been
redone to each party's like best
performance right but in terms of the
senate it was always a tough match
because most of the defendant seats were
real d aligners they're moving to the
right not to the left and we ran you
know
and we the republican party has designed
a system to make sure their turnout does
not decline and they and in 21 in
virginia this system has now been
perfected so much they hit their
presidential turnout numbers in their
best precincts so like when you look at
trump performance and glenn younkin
performance it is equal in their best
precincts
right so you're so you're saying you're
saying in
in the districts where where these
republicans are turning out specifically
exactly and what they did with that
strata it's it's literally the same
strategy i wanted to run in virginia you
know and i was trying to explain to them
look we're gonna shut we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna lose statewide vote
like the statewide total is gonna shed
and here's specifically where it's gonna
shed in the state legislature and within
these state legislative seats we
actually know exactly who's vulnerable
to shed and to conversion because a lot
of that 10 conversion pool is not well
informed they're not they don't know any
of these recent news events that we've
been talking about for two months and
they're imagistic so if the media is
talking about ukraine or russia and and
inflation that's all that that gonna
ever is going to permeate them the top
top level of the news cycle so that's
why my strategy
in addition to these this tweaked you
know electioneering system within each
state is really focused on narrative
right because because at the end of the
day
it's that generic ballot that we talk
about you know do you want republicans
or democrats to control congress and
what we're seeing in that data
predominantly is a combination of a
depressed like left-leaning independent
field who are you know they're not
partisans and they don't know that the
republicans are screwing with democrats
because we don't tell them so they're
they're turned off they're like man
these people said they were going to fix
it and then they don't you know they
actually fixed 100 things but the five
things that they didn't fix is what the
newspaper right right right so you that
it's all about large narrative and what
concerns me
is that we didn't get that in 2020 the
narrative down ballot should have been
the same as up ballot you cannot trust
these people with your health wealth and
safety they're [ __ ] nuts right
whether it's city council school board
whatever it is all the way down you
don't want these people in charge of
your life because they're [ __ ] nuts
right so how do we so how do we get how
do we get to a point where we have we
have that top line
um
the top line personal narrative right
and so we can't do that until all these
tactical deployments we have are running
on one mission or i can build an
alternative infrastructure that's siloed
out and can deploy and play
in all of these races so you're talking
about 50 million right so like operation
fire alarm
which i've been running publicly with my
bd appearances and on twitter
since the beginning of december is about
getting people to understand as of today
not only are the fundamentals
guaranteeing us to lose we don't have
the right system in place and we have
about three we really about april to get
it in place so what i'm doing now is
really oriented to waking up the
electioneering system of the left and
letting it know as of today we know what
we're doing isn't working because that
generic ballot is still favoring
republicans so is it that our highway
system kind of given an out here is it
that our highway system is shitty or we
just don't have one at all yeah we don't
have one so like there's institutions
and people want to give jamie harrison
[ __ ] right jamie runs an institution
okay that institution does a lot of [ __ ]
and it like kind of oversees some of the
electioneering strategy it doesn't run
[ __ ] elections okay right and then
down at these individual committee
levels like those are run by the
consultants basically i mean consultants
come to the these people aren't [ __ ]
election experts right so and they're
not and they're not they're not doing
the top line no personalized narrative
that we're talking about right they're
not they're not executing stupid they
don't know to do that because the
consultant world decides each campaign
is run as a separate [ __ ] thing dude
right and that's not how that's not how
the other side works oh [ __ ] no because
like glenn younkin ran the campaign
strategy he ran was created at the rnc
and then given to them or they you know
brought the people in to run it and
they're going to run that campaign
everywhere right right so so let me ask
you so
speaking of glenn juncken could they
have brought any [ __ ] rube with it
with a sweater vest in and done that
yeah do you think oh yeah any anyone not
completely tied a hundred percent to
trump with this
tony they could not they needed a rich
one
when when no one other than me knew
virginia could be flipping um they you
know glenn younkin had to do a lot of
independent financing but they weren't
stupid they understood like mid-term
cycle they [ __ ] aren't
they are well-versed in political
science right over there let me just
tell you and so they knew that it would
be if they're they have a chance to win
on the on the cycle and so they actually
what they did is closed off their
primary process and switched it to a
convention and made it like basically a
party decides convention and gave the
nomination to yunken because he was
digestible and very very wealthy
independently so he can finance himself
and get to the point where once the
polls caught up because what i'm trying
to tell people is what what they're
going to see in september right and in
september you're going to see these
close polls you know you may even see
democrats ahead in places like a couple
points by the end of the [ __ ] day
when those ballots get cast if you're
not running this this targeting model
and the right messaging like that the
polling is never going to match reality
right because we're not going to get
that generic ballot that you're talking
about we're not going to we're not going
to see that turnout right because we've
got to get those they get all the people
who have two so like i have really
awesome [ __ ] friends and they're
super educated and smart people i had
just hung out with them for dinner the
other night i had to bring them up to
speed on every news development of the
last month
right because they're because what what
are they what are they worried about
they're worried about democratic
collapse because they hang out with me
and nobody gets to hang out with me and
feel good
especially in this timeline right and
they're a perfect little focus group too
because they're all you know they're
democrats or liberals they're going to
vote every time pretty much but like
they they are [ __ ] over the
negativity they don't want to talk about
it they don't want to look at this thing
coming at them people that's natural
human behavior is to ostrich away from
from shitty stuff especially once you've
been forced to marinate in it for a long
time so like these these guys aren't
special i mean they're my friends but
they're not special every [ __ ] buddy
listen this podcast has those friends
who are
you know oh did they do that and you can
tell they're not following along and
that their heart isn't in it we have to
[ __ ] make sure that those people are
scared shitless not to vote right
stay pissed and go [ __ ] vote as i say
all the time conversion pool we gotta
give them option a option b that's the
gop is gonna hit us and they're gonna
brand us like the shittiest [ __ ]
thing on earth that's all that their
advertising strategy accomplishes right
brand um brand breakage branding it's
all about it doesn't matter about the
individual candidate it's the party that
they run against right right right now i
i mean i don't know this for a fact that
i suspect our strategy is even more
candidate specific
not right that's right
and what i wanted to do with glenn
younkin and and no one had an appetite
was i was like no [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] if he is moderate dude yeah [ __ ]
him i mean he you know he can if he can
run like larry hogan or michael steele
and say this is wrong and the election
was legitimate that'd be one thing okay
but he wasn't gonna be
but he's not a [ __ ] moderate he was
willing to tow the big lie it was clear
that he was biding his time and i was
like let me paint for virginia reality
underneath duncan
well [ __ ] it virginia's already paying
already paying for that no now they're
seeing it after the fact right that's
what i'm saying before right right well
that's what i'm saying though the the
the citizens of the state of virginia
are going wait a second no [ __ ] wait a
second this isn't what you said which
you know we we could have called that
all day long every day that ends and why
is that that glenn younkin wasn't going
to bring what he was what he was telling
them that it's all [ __ ] lies i wanted
people so like they want to talk about
race and education and like the
mcauliffe team jumps right into that
hole right and i'm like no [ __ ]
if they're going to bring up crt let's
hit them with dead kids dude right let's
be like look these are the [ __ ]
children all around america and the
teachers by the way that the republican
party murdered with their pandemic
management because well because they
kept spreading the lies and the [ __ ]
so let me ask you this tony if i had
dropped that ad and i accused literally
rick desantis of killing children do you
think the news cycle would still be
focused on see [ __ ] rt
right like who is this person accusing
him of being
a head of a death goal [ __ ]
but that's what i say when i when it's
about the narrative if we're not winning
the narrative in the media then we're
not winning the day right so to me we
have 200 i haven't looked at the clock
260 or something right left to the
election 260 days and for me every day
is like do they talk more about
republicans in the media or more about
democrats and if we don't make sure that
of these 260 days that are left the news
cycle is predominantly focused on their
[ __ ] upness then we're going to lose
this midterm it's just that simple well
you know a good example that and we're
going to talk about this on the other
side of the break with gabe um is this
rogan spotify everyone wanted to go
after spotify and as soon as the rock
entered the chat and the rock is has to
apologize because he realizes that joe
rogan has made complete
bio-racist remarks throughout his career
and they pulled this video from alex
jones it resurfaces
i think patriot takes post it on their
page and all of a sudden all of a sudden
the rock has to
with a lot of class say okay this isn't
right and and all of a sudden the
national narrative goes from spotify to
oh my god
how how in the hell could anyone support
him saying this racist vile [ __ ] right
like in an instant the message switched
and i believe we can do that with what
you're saying right we can do the same
thing it takes a little bit of that
strategic outrage to flip that messaging
no it takes strategic [ __ ] planning
tony and that that's why not having a
general and a war room with a war
cabinet that's condensed hierarchical
and able to move aggressively and very
very fast
is such a strategic disadvantage to us
that i i have no choice but to sit here
on every you know day on twitter and and
in media saying we have to build this
war room right now or we're going to
lose right right otherwise
4 000 people deciding how this is going
to get shook out and there will be no
manipulation of the narrative in that
kind of system right well i appreciate
you joining us today and everyone in the
comments loved your video um you know
like it turns my stomach when i watch
these clips um uh let's see a beautiful
song over top of ugly violence um so
that that ad is having an effect so um
if you if you're not following rachel go
follow rachel and strike back over on
twitter and uh you know spread that
thing around the interwebs like herpes
or something yeah maybe yeah like a like
a venereal disease so because if we
don't we're gonna have a venereal
disease that takes over our country yeah
i'd rather have herpes and syphilis yeah
well you know that's right
i'm forced to choose well if you gotta
if you gotta flip a coin you know
i'd have to look both of these things up
i'm not gonna lock in on her you're not
you're not you're not you're not going
to place your bet is that what you're
saying well you know you know it happens
sometimes rachel thanks for joining us i
hope you come back next week because i
know i know what will happen over the
next weekend there'll be some more
[ __ ] they'll give us more more
ammunition uh to save democracy with the
ballot so thanks a lot i like loading up
the [ __ ] army on monday so they have
a lot of [ __ ] to do all week let's do it
let's do it all right thanks for thanks
for thanks for giving us all the ammo
for the [ __ ] army rachel we'll talk
to you soon have a good one stay with us
we'll be right back after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i always like getting rachel on even if
we have to talk about venereal diseases
where
we're going to the break you know i
don't i don't know which one i would use
maybe we should uh maybe we should ask
gabe which uh venereal disease he would
uh he would take on gabe what what
venereal disease would you uh would you
choose if you had if you had an option i
mean are you gonna be all in on one or
the other uh okay well well here's the
thing you know are you looking for
something that you want to live with for
the rest of your life that's like a bit
of a nuisance mm-hmm or what could be
worse
uh or do you want something that you can
just cure up and like go away right
because you know because because
syphilis while it can have long-term
detrimental effects like al capone
neurosci um
right he lost his mind he lost right
right that's i also have this theory
that that's the same thing that happened
with trump okay and he he was treated
but a little bit later uh however
uh you can cure it
and be gone with it and then you're done
or you can say like hey i want the
herpes route why come on the [ __ ] are we
talking about this anyway
you can go to the hurt route and you can
have it for your whole life right right
it's like
it stays with you right right it and you
can control it but it stays with you
forever you know it kind of sounds like
it kind of sounds like fascism right
like right there are flare-ups there are
flare-ups right it's always underneath
the surface and it takes one trigger of
something to
to get the switch
flipped and and get it going so um not
not to get off the venereal disease
subject because i really yeah i know i
would love to stay i would love to stay
there i would love to stay there um but
uh we had a we had a lot of
[ __ ] happen with the joe rogan thing
over the weekend we actually we entered
the chat believe it or not we did we're
part of the cabal i guess i guess i
guess so by like association
yeah well i mean um
so so
there was there was a lot of things that
happened uh first first of all first of
all there was a picture that ended up
you showing you in the capital and a lot
of people were were mad that you were
smearing [ __ ] on the wall wow uh
something that's what happens when you
party at the capitol well right
political discourse is what it was
just just just ordinary
everyone
and i'm trying to i'm trying to find the
uh the the picture here i guess it's uh
on your timeline but um also there was
something else that you really pissed
off the fact checkers because
it's hard to tell if that picture is
real or not really i mean it's very
i mean you almost made it to where it
was impossible to tell if this yeah this
picture of you and the camera there's no
no way that you would be able to tell if
that was real or not right right so
believable but speaking of real speaking
real there was also an instance where
you may or may not have pissed off um
daniel dale
and a few others but yeah they all
specifically yeah i uh uh i guess
uh my press releases are that believable
to people which is you know that's the
reality we live in right like where it's
like satire parody they're completely
dead we've talked about it other people
have brought it up it's just like
the fact that yeah here we go there it
was dude it was a grand old time with a
good old boys you know look at look at
gabe here with his with his legitimate
manga hat on yeah
smearing [ __ ] as this guy points at his
dick i'm not sure what richard biggo
barnett yeah well and and this is his
handle here and please do not whatever
you do do not go
do not go um um
whatever did he did he turned it to
private though didn't he yeah he turned
it to private i did request uh to follow
i don't know if he's blocked me oh okay
so so you actually you actually want to
follow this guy yeah i'm trying to get
in those dms man you know i'm trying to
i'm trying to be like remember me
remember those good times look at the
picture that we had at the capitol it's
amazing look at us
i mean you look like you're having a
good old time here now yeah
so so this is obviously
real right exactly and that it
so so let me ask you let me ask you the
other uh fake thing real thing that
happened is you actually flew down the
mar-a-lago yeah you snuck into
mar-a-lago right you snuck in you
appeared to be the press release guy did
you bring like your typewriter or
something or how did how did you manage
how did you manage to get your statement
on to the former guys right right right
well here's the thing i didn't use a
typewriter i i was able to log into his
uh
to his computer um and if anyone's
wondering the password is uh i love you
ivanka
oh is it is it right yeah if you're
listening yeah you're wanting to hack i
went through a list of other things i
tried like adderall
i tried
uh you know let's go brandon
uh you know all these different things
uh it turns out it was i love you ivanka
was the right one oh okay okay what's it
what about what about i guess i forgot
about don jr did you try that one or
maybe maybe he just doesn't know don
yeah right
[Laughter]
so here is here's here's the statement
that you snuck into mar-a-lago to make
right take the banner down here um so so
we can see this really well uh daniel
dale as everyone knows daniel dale is
the
uh cnn fact checker for trump basically
the last six years daniel dale has
continually uh fact check which he's
done a very good job right i mean i like
daniel but in this case it's a little
ridiculous right yeah don't you agree
it's a little ridiculous that this is
this is this is the things that we have
to do that we have to fact check parity
and obvious parity surely someone knows
that this is obvious parody right right
uh you would hope that when you read it
i mean this is the second time the first
time i got backed up by reuters and usa
today and some uh business times and
uh i actually this is this is for this
is for a statement that you that you may
or may not have snuck into mar-a-lago to
write right exactly this was like this
was
a month ago we talked about it on the
show yeah yeah i don't know time i don't
know any i don't know what time is
anymore right right exactly but yeah so
this goes out what was it thursday
friday
i totally forget now
yeah so anyway the february 4th so yeah
it was friday friday yeah yes i know 5
p.m is when daniel right right because
it was five hours after um right you
snuck into mar-a-lago and made this day
so what happened was pence made this
speech and he said trump is wrong i
could not overturn the election so then
i thought hey uh
let's get ahead of this one
and
get the release out there so that people
know what trump is thinking
and my release said
uh you know
many people are saying
that president or that vice president
mike pence
uh would i say it said here here many
people are saying vice president mike
pence said i was wrong about overturning
the election he's wrong
he could have overturned the election of
course he said this at a federal society
event with no press and he wouldn't say
it in public because he's weak so so
president trump um
here's the thing gabe you're better at
writing trump than trump is right
and and here's my theory right so this
you you put this out um it's like 20
minutes maybe after the speech is given
right so this is
right so this is
so silly audience knows mike pence went
to the federal society event uh there
was no press actually allowed in the
event so you're actually telling the
truth in this statement there's nothing
really
that you're saying wrong here i mean
things were broad they were things were
broadcasted but press was not like the
media was barred so when people are
coming in they're like oh no i saw it on
my cnn
let's let's back up a step you saw
footage that they released to these
places right but this event if you look
it up had the media bar you couldn't the
media couldn't go in there and be like
there was there was no cnn camera there
was no abc nbc yeah there were no
reporters in there who could you know
report on it they were getting a feed
right
all they saw is what they saw right
right exactly now so
so pence gets up on stage and basically
says [ __ ] donald trump donald trump's
wrong for thinking that i can overturn
the election that's not a thing that can
happen that's anti-american i mean he
says pretty much as much as that which
um completely [ __ ] probably made uh
the former guy just yeah
himself right he's pissed he had to have
been pissed throwing [ __ ] no one should
i don't know how many tvs he probably
broke and how he defecated himself right
a couple times you know they probably
needed a couple new packages of [ __ ]
depends in the meantime but here's the
thing here's what i here's my theory
this statement real or not goes out on
the internet
some people uh realize what it is some
people don't realize what it is i mean
daniel dale obviously uh recognized that
some people wasn't getting it so that he
put a big red x i crossed your [ __ ]
screenshot tweet i got
freaking daniel dale bro right so so
here's what i think happened and stay
with me here
the pence thing happens
the former guy is [ __ ] pissed they're
trying to change his diapers they're
trying to give him some adderall they're
trying to calm him down right in the
meantime this statement goes around the
internet
and they had a statement written and it
is probably so [ __ ] close to this
statement
like like it is probably almost to the
letter to this [ __ ] statement they
were ready to release and they're like
ah [ __ ] gabe sanchez gets two steps
ahead of us and that's why they had to
go with the [ __ ] the statement that
they went with because the statement
that they went with trump did not write
that there's no way
no no it was definitely more uh while
still ridiculous it was more civil
in what was said i mean he called pence
a rhino and all this you know some other
nicknames for stuff out there but also
you also convey your belt like he's just
just a hodgepodge of words he's throwing
in these things now don't you think
don't you see in the room where they're
like oh this [ __ ] fake ass statement
is exactly what we want to say and so
they're trying to figure out like i'm
just snowballing here yeah yeah this is
what i want the video to be if anyone's
going to make video of it
just dropping hints there so i don't
know maybe we get john walsh to help us
in a collaboration but listen so so he's
in the room he's [ __ ] pissed he [ __ ]
his diaper he's throwing things he's mad
at the tv he's mad at you that you took
his [ __ ] statement you stole his
[ __ ] words so like mr president sit
down because they still call him mr
president you know right yeah you know
he he probably requires it if you're in
his presence to say that oh totally so
they finally calm him down and they're
like you tell us what you want us to
write and he just starts going right
yeah and they're writing all this stuff
and they're like well we can't say that
exactly and that doesn't make sense we
have to make it a sentence and like so
they're trying to you know yeah like we
need to put some punctuation in there
right right right because the only
capitals like the only all caps that
they had was the word rhino which is
always in all caps right exactly yeah so
i don't actually believe that
it was him because there was no all caps
that's why your statement here even
though daniel dale had to put a big red
x
and i will say this like there are
people out there that you know there are
some people that have been uh
or rather the only there's only a couple
people it'd be daniel dale and someone
else um
who expressed i was actually i didn't
even know this but they had expressed uh
an annoyance with
seeing these things
what what do you what do you mean by
that what do you what do you mean see
seeing what types of things you mean you
mean comedy and parody yeah like they
see something oh look somebody did a
parody of this somebody did something
satirical of this whatever it is like oh
somebody made a copy and a lot of people
got felt duped do those same people feel
duped when they watch a deep fake of tom
cruise beating someone up in a group
like in a
uh in a convenience store and then find
out oh it actually or counter reeves or
whatever that video was like do these
people watch that and they get duped and
go oh man like i'm so pissed you know or
is it the fact that
like what is it right like you're
getting mad at the fact that people are
believing this stuff i'm sorry but
that's the reality we live in we can't
tell what is fact or fiction now and the
fact that i'm making fun of it
people get upset at or like you know a
few people get upset other people are
like this is crazy
sad and hilarious all in one uh they
also go on to say like oh i can't
believe this would happen at the same
time i can believe it would happen like
that is where we are right now where
we've allowed this [ __ ] idiot to be
in office for four years and shift
the just
completely like the complete way of
thinking that people have to say like
yeah i guess that's possible which is
like that would never be a thing before
that right and when you look at the
statement of like
yeah anything's possible like before it
had a positive connotation like yeah
anything is possible you can do it and
now it's like
anything's possible right no it's like
that's where we are and so these people
that like have this i don't think it's
warranted and for people to be upset at
it i'm like
there are tons of other things happening
right now that you can focus on put your
effort toward that don't get pissed
about this
get pissed about something else that
actually has weight in substance well
the other thing too is the strategic
outrage that like rachel's talking about
like if you are going to get pissed off
about this statement maybe maybe what
you should do is not be pissed off about
the person who made the parody maybe you
should be pissed off at the people who
are the parody right right like like i i
even said i even tweeted it after this
because i watch people go after you that
oh my god you need to put a warning
label on this and i'm like look it if it
if you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] need a
warning label it's not parody anymore
it's not now it may trick you in the
moment and you may be like oh tony
called me a dumb [ __ ] because i i
thought it was real in an instant yeah
but you finally came to realize that
okay this isn't real but that's the
point of parody like you can't like if i
yeah if the fact that i have to you know
i'll put i'll tag my handle on other
stuff when it's like clearly this is not
real but i want because i've had my
stuff stolen before but i also want to
make sure i get you know rightful
ownership but on this stuff if i put my
handle on there
then it takes away from the fact that
like i'm sorry that you've that you felt
duped right but right in the grand
scheme of things is that really what
you're upset about right you're mad at
you're mad at you are you mad that that
statement could be [ __ ] real right
and so when i direct your anger towards
the right [ __ ] direction exactly and
if you're pissed off the fact that like
oh this could be real let's break it
down and go to the source who are the
people that are one actually sharing the
stuff from trump that he's saying maybe
get mad at those people and then also
look at the fact of like
maybe we should never allow this thing
to ever happen again maybe the person
that was in office that's now making
these press releases was never qualified
in the first place and has destroyed the
company or destroyed the country
and put ourselves in a position where
we're like we don't know what's real and
what's not real so maybe
focus your energy and your outrage and
your anger and your dedication to making
sure that it doesn't happen again by
electing people who will ensure it
doesn't by electing people who are
actually competent and actually having
the intelligence and the boring boring
as [ __ ]
as [ __ ] but you know what they're doing
don't get pissed at me because you know
what sorry not sorry i made a thing
and people fell for it and i found it
hilarious and a lot of people did too
and there's probably a few people out
there that didn't find it funny but i'm
sorry if you're the people that are out
there going like i've got to fact check
you sorry it's called job security and i
just helped you right right well you
know and i i i appreciate daniel dale on
the work he's done right exactly and but
i think
i think it's actually i think it's
fantastic and it should speak to people
who are you know again who are mad at
this who are aiming their their anger
and their outrage in the opposite
direction they should be aiming it at is
that the daniel dale putting the x
across it should should make people go
holy [ __ ]
even the trump fact checker
has to [ __ ] fact check this fake
statement because it is so close to
reality
what what don't you understand about
that so so uh um daniel if you're out
there we would love for you to come on
the show and talk about we are we are
fans of your work we appreciate you know
i'm sure that you go through a ton of
therapy we'll give you some [ __ ] we'll
give you some [ __ ] we'll give you some
[ __ ] about the red x you know but but i
know you can handle it you're you're a
tough smart guy come on the show
we'll talk to you about the statement
speaking of weird things that we ended
up in the news for because we kind of
ended up in this timeline of of an
account called vocal or something yeah
never heard of it until right you sent
me this tweet yeah so let's let's um let
me pull this up here um this is this is
the actual drop in the in the thread
that happened um what this is is this is
a tweet that we sent out november 17th
okay
it says live in five minutes
with brett and jordy mizella's from
midas touch uh brett and jordy explain
why midas mighty are so important to our
democracy and of course it gives the
link
to the full episode which i'm really
glad they promoted inside this vocal
right
yeah i'm cool with that we actually got
some views on it because people like
whoa what is this cabal stuff right
so apparently we are now part of the the
cabal um this is a clip and i'm not even
gonna play this is a clip from
our show that brett and jordy from midas
touch was on right yeah um and we were
playing trivia right and this is the
clip that we used to promote the show on
twitter and it's basically us um playing
well bretton's already playing trivia
but it's a funny clip yeah it's a
playing sports trivia right right and
and there there's some words in there
about stop the steel and you know
obviously again the whole uh you don't
know what parody is and it's not parody
and it's not joking if you need a
[ __ ] warning label right um but it
ends up in this thread which i want to
go to here
um so this is the thread that happened
and there was a bunch of events because
this has to do with joe rogan
and spotify right so explain to the
audience
some of the timeline of events here
because um just just so we're all on the
same page as we right right so
to kind of back it up uh alex jones you
know in the typical fashion has some
sort of like falling out with another
person who
is either from the right wing spreading
propaganda whatever you know that that
side and so he and joe rogan got into a
tiff
alex jones made a video a compilation
video of joe rogan saying the n word
numerous times if you ever need a
compilation that's a bad sign right he
made a compilation
joe rogan's getting called out about
things that he said his jokes his
stand-ups all this stuff
this video resurfaces and patriot takes
then shares it right it goes [ __ ]
viral right so so basically basically
because patriot takes um calls out the
right wing but they also call out videos
like this when people are acting a fool
and in this clip that alex jones and
infowars made it it really makes
joe rogan look like he's acting a fool
right right because he's like oh you
know
you got to understand because then there
was because there was the apology that
joe rogan made and he's like well you
got to understand the context and you
just got to look at it like you know if
you understood the joke it wasn't
actually racist whenever you're like oh
you got to understand the context of why
i'm saying the n word listen as a
comedian you could probably do the joke
better and without the n word right like
if you're a white dude saying the n word
and then trying to excuse yourself and
give context
no that doesn't no the only context is
you said the n word you did you need to
say it probably not right well no the
other the other the other part is that
he not only apologized because this
video went viral like you said and this
video existed it was out there it's not
like it was hidden and the other thing
too is all the clips in it they still
exist out there it's not like someone
you know secretly recorded joe rogan
saying the n-word yeah it's not what
happened you could go to youtube and you
could actually go through and you know
this is what alex jones is probably what
they did
and they went through all the stuff and
they found all the clips where he was
saying something racist how many days do
you think they [ __ ] spend on this i
mean it's those interviews are like
three hours i know and he's got over a
thousand well i mean someone someone who
is joe rogan's um you know
uh i want to call him enemy but you know
someone who's got it out for him had to
have found these things throughout the
years and oh i'm sure someone will place
time stamps in these episodes yeah i'm
sure yeah somebody was tabulated and
they still had to go find these clips
and exactly the video really isn't put
together that well like right it's just
him yeah yeah so this happens and then
this vocal now wait wait wait wait wait
because because that is the apology for
the video that we're talking about he
also apologized um um
for his misinformation on covid before
this
and then and then uh and said
i'll bring on voices from both sides so
it's not just heavily weighted so that
way we can balance it right right so so
so then spotify actually takes down like
70 as episodes right right and then this
video happens um he does the really
weird what did you call it the uh during
you called it the a thumb interview what
did you call it oh uh he looks like a
thumb yeah he always points the camera
underneath him or like really close he's
got this like thumb face going on right
here because he's you know he's just
give us a good give us a good exa
[Laughter]
you know he's got his thumb head and
he's got a shaved head and so it just
looks like right yeah a thumb you know
right right well
i i like the description so so he does
this thumb this thumb uh apology for
this video right and what happens in the
rogan universe right these alpha cucks
because that's really who he speaks to a
lot oh yeah i would i would imagine if
you really did like a survey i would
imagine that at least 50 percent of his
audience's alpha cucks just just that
alone right oh yeah easily yeah
and if anyone doesn't know what alpha
cux is tune in on on friday afternoons
um at the second hour of the show and
during bone of the week and you'll
you'll discover what alpha cuck means
but but um uh
it has to be a lot of these alpha cucks
right and they lost their [ __ ] minds
speaking of alpha cucks
what happens with this vocal tweet
is dave portnoy and i don't really know
who the [ __ ] this douchebag is dave
portnoy but i know he's a douchebag he
interviewed trump once he's with
barstool sports
he's also got a uh
uh he's also
the
um
had a ton of allegations against him for
you know sexual misconduct
details right well i mean i mean let's
face it bar stool stores as an
organization is is racist misogynistic
sexist i mean you you you name it um
they got it over there and it's
intentional right like even he even says
it out loud he's like it's controversial
like right like intentionally we want
you to be shocked you know like
it's the same thing that rogan does and
they [ __ ] about oh people trying to
cancel us because of our views no it's
not your views it's that you voice them
and you aim them you punch down you're
always punching down you dumb
[ __ ] and and and comedy because
he claims to be it's all comedy and it's
all you know this or that but comedy has
always been um a weapon to punch up and
it's always been a weapon to bring truth
to power and when you're not using it
that way
you're [ __ ] punching down and you're
not doing it correctly and they get mad
when people hold them accountable
speaking of that joe rogan uh this video
comes out
joe rogan releases an apology um but don
winslow which everyone knows in my
audience that i don't always get along
with don and don's welcome on the show
too to talk about this yeah i sent a
message absolutely welcome on the show
because i i actually give credit to don
for tweeting at the rock i think he
actually tweeted the video right the
video the alex jones video that patriot
takes but uh tweeted it to rock and said
hey rock are you okay with this yes yeah
yeah that's what it did yeah yeah and
and that's when the rock responded
because the rock was defending rogan for
uh you know a minute right until this
video really surfaced and and the rock
and all true class like turned in an
instant um and and
in response to this tweet from don
winslow um which could shifted the
entire debate
from should we should we boycott spotify
to uh no joe rogan is a [ __ ] racist
because
you know we talk about this in private
and also i've talked about it on the
show is that i think anyone who
personally doesn't want to give their
money to spotify i think that's
appropriate to do um it is not however a
good idea to de-platform pro-democracy
voices from platforms like spotify
because they own like 50 percent of the
podcast universe and if we d platform
ourselves like if i took my cuz i could
take my show off spotify but i'm not
going to and the reason why is because i
i feel like
my voice and our show is a rebuttal to
some of the [ __ ] that joe rogan the
misinformation and the [ __ ] the
misogyny that this this [ __ ]
stupid-ass uh macho machismo type type
thing that they do over there and the
bar stool sports the same way i think
our voice we can manage to do that and
aim it in the correct direction right we
don't we can go after the alco alpha
cucks with which with this mckeesmo
stuff it it can work that way right it
all goes back to messaging and
everything else
so i i got very disappointed when i seen
people d platforming themselves people
that have very good messages people need
to hear that message and by d platform
itself
hundreds of thousands of people aren't
going to hear that message on spotify
and if they don't hear it on spotify
they may you know i i made a couple
personal phone calls they said well
maybe they'll jump over to another
platform like come on
you know
why are you making your audience jump to
another platform right if it's there and
you have a message and you want to send
it because i think pro democracy should
be loud and clear and here's why
with this vocal thing because in this
tweet it says since you ask i love your
work i'll tell you
uh this is a professional political
attack right professional political
attack so um what they're doing in this
this vocal thread is they're they're
saying that the attack on joe rogan is
purely political which is really [ __ ]
dumb joe rogan isn't affiliated with any
party that i know of do you know is he
affiliated with any political group
uh i
specifically i mean is he is he a
republican i mean he he he endorsed
bernie sanders who was running right but
i don't know if he is i mean i haven't
seen what his voting record is or like
his registration but like
i mean like he obviously sides with or
he feeds into the conservative side
because he sees that's where like the
money's coming from but he did endorse
bernie sanders but also it's like before
the pandemic he was also yeah
pro-vaccine and now his anti-vaccine so
i don't know if there was some sort of
like
don't you think that joe rogan says the
[ __ ] into the microphone that his
audience is going to love and that's why
he's paid 100 million dollars by spotify
so it says three waves one right after
the other is not a coincidence what the
what what what what are they talking
about here because this is the question
who y'all think is behind the attack on
rogan yeah right that's the that's the
that's the tweet here that they're
responding to
and they're gonna tell us who it is here
right and here it is
um of course uh here's the official
statement by patriot takes a screenshot
and the screenshot of the video of the
tweet here's the screenshot here
that they posted this local account
right and then uh damn it all right okay
here's the here's the actual uh
statement
this is the response to the joe rogan
apology which you should go read it
um
you know i think you should but the
point is is this local distance whoever
this is says the video compilation of
rogan saying the n word was dropped by
at patriotic six days ago
all right we're not talking about this
was dropped and then all of a sudden
um you know this vocal thread comes up
you see the video in the tweet and pick
one and patriotics takes credit for
republishing quote unquote
it was republished by the way the info
and pick two
so um
now if you go down just a bit more here
we go
as you can see in their bio which is
very this is a very secret thing by the
way it's really hard to go see patriot
takes bio as you can see in their bio
patriot takes is partnered with midas
touch and then it says who
who is midas touch
who is like it's
as if like like you know what's funny
about super pacs is they're all secret
and [ __ ] right no one knows who's behind
them but midas touch is not like that at
all like yeah the exact opposite their
account is online they say who they are
they've been written up about uncovered
they [ __ ] talk about it if you were
to if you were if you were just to type
this into duckduckgo you would find out
what the answer is dick go is that what
you said yeah did go get get go so so
patriot takes this is obviously a
screenshot from their account this is
not fake this is real partner with midas
touch as if it's some kind of big
[ __ ] secret that they're partnering
with them right
um and then you know you see uh they
pull up an article uh about the myself
brothers here and then um i think even
the word cabal gets entered into the
chat doesn't it somewhere here uh let's
see where is it where is it
might not be local it might be a person
responding to local
and then cabal
right right or it might be local i
forget i mean they're like doing this
whole like investigative uh
investigative journalism here where
they're trying to say like well look we
looked at the profile and based on the
profile it says that these people are
involved and they're in association with
this group and this group is probably
the ones that are funding them and
they're the ones who are secretly the
cabal behind this whole uh strategic
attack they're even highlighting the
statement that patriotics put on their
[ __ ] twitter as if you know look here
look whenever they lie whenever i see
people do this i'm like what are you
proving they came out and said
that
they you know like they released this
video they have a partnership on a legal
side
uh
that
they have been open about they and then
which then led into a thing that
happened yesterday last night on youtube
and they talked about it right right so
so what ends up happening is and and i'm
gonna i'm gonna give credit here that
his tweet sucks your tweet [ __ ] sucks
dude
you suck and it sucks to suck
and and twitter's gonna say do you sure
you wanna tweet that yeah we wanna
[ __ ] tweet that [ __ ] okay so um what
happened is how we ended up in this chat
right is that people were were i guess
searching you know i'm not sure
what the [ __ ]
that's good come on come on one more one
more maybe
uh people were searching maybe not maybe
not maybe not people were searching for
um
i guess content for the mizellas
brothers i guess that's how how this
clip of ours ended up in this thread the
the uh the damning content
that is the of us playing brett and
jordy playing trivia with us sports
trivia right so this is like
and there's no there's no like
content here it's just like they just
dropped this like hey look here right
and that's how i entered the chat um
they're like look see these two guys
they've got the midas touch logo in the
background that's how we know it's them
right right right
what
which what's funny about this is they're
like oh they're doing this all in secret
it's some kind of secret political
operation like jordy here is sitting in
front of a [ __ ] lighted sign that
says midas touch on it this is like the
people who are like oh and george soros
and the democrats have secretly planned
a whole thing about the election where
they're gonna they're gonna take them or
they're gonna over
overturn everything and they're gonna
you know put joe biden and this and that
and it's like oh yeah the plan where we
just like narrowly got 50 50 on the
senate and we lost some seats in the
house and we only got the presidency
yeah crazy secret plan where right we
just don't have your control to make
sure everything
yeah ridiculous ridiculous i mean i mean
we we do get our soros checks every week
gabe i mean we do get them and they are
humongous like they're big and he sends
several of them every weekend i mean
this whole room right now this is just a
set this is not even my oh this is a
green screen behind me that soros
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] and and the the best part is
dave portnoy enters the chat right and
what he does is he he retweets this
local thread right as if it's some kind
of cabal and i think the reason why
because last night on midas touch's
youtube channel and you guys can go
watch this over there
dave portnoy actually goes on their
[ __ ] channel
um and to to quote unquote debate them
about this issue which i don't even know
what the debate actually is um
especially from portnoy's perspective
like what
uh other other than he's really [ __ ]
pissed off that an account called resist
programming is that what it's called
yeah yeah i think that's what it's
called i i and i think i follow them too
so i mean if and apparently if you
follow them and they follow you back you
are definitely part of the cabal like
there's no question right you know
because you can't follow someone and
they follow you back on twitter like it
has to be some kind of conspiracy if
that happens
but
um dave portnoy the president of
barstool sports do you know do you watch
this [ __ ] do you know anything about
this [ __ ] idiot nope nope okay the
only time i've ever seen it is uh
is when he's reviewing
uh pizza
oh okay he does like these reviews of
like
uh
frozen pizzas i think [ __ ] sounds like
yeah yeah like real real good stuff but
basically like what i see is whenever i
it's on instagram i don't follow like i
don't i don't the only time i've ever
seen portnoy is when he has uh
there was a video of
don jr or a photo by jon jr and he was
like oh look it's the president with el
presidente because he was at the white
house interviewing him
and
uh
and then i saw a video on instagram once
of him doing a pizza review because
somebody was like
this is this you know for a client
they're like this is the style like
testimonial organic testimonial that we
want done
uh but that's the only time i've ever
like interacted with
portnoy online uh until this moment
which i was like
right this is a sad attempt at trying to
like this gotcha moment where he's like
i go i got you i figured it out you guys
are the ones that are funding this whole
secret attack and it's like
we're not though
yeah well and it's kind of crazy because
he's pissed off that this resist
programming i guess takes a clip of him
um
saying racist [ __ ] or what what appears
to be racist [ __ ] i haven't seen the
actual clip where he's railing on colin
kaepernick right
um and apparently this which by the way
when they were talking he just brought
up kaepernick because you guys are cap
guys right you guys are cap fans like
out of nowhere as an excuse to say how
an association with the video or quote
that was released uh of of him against
kaepernick and them retweeting resist uh
programming or liking their post or
following them at some point was in any
way a correlation between like these
guys are behind this group that's
attacking the or is making the
anti-portnoy like whatever and it's like
listen you got your own
[ __ ] going on
uh
yeah and it was just like one of those
when i watched the conversation i was or
like the conversation
he tried to switch topics several times
and that was one of the like ridiculous
where he's like shift and ben was like
hey let's just come back to the actual
topic at hand right now
right well i actually let's let's um
i can pull it up here this is on the
midas touch uh channel here
and and this is this is portnoy here
let's pull down this banner
because the relevance of this is that
the the accusations against rogan is
that he's a racist and that is and that
his words aren't his words but it's
really [ __ ] weird that people are
like oh you have to go after howard
stern if you don't go after howard stern
or you don't go after this person you
don't go after that person then it's not
a legitimate attack on on rogan and what
you're saying about rogan isn't true
like what are you talking about the
[ __ ] video says what he says what he
says and if you judge him the way that
you judge him well that's your [ __ ]
opinion based on the [ __ ] what his
words are right what are you talking
about it doesn't get rid of what he said
it's like
this vocal account that shared it tried
to make it seem like there was this
again this cabal like they had they had
edited the video together and they had
put it in in a place where they're like
great we're going to have patreon take
shared on our behalf and and it was like
no that's not what happened alex jones
his people did it they found it it
resurfaced they shared it again because
it was a as you know i think brett said
he's like we're in the tornado of joe
rogan this is the breeze that's coming
out right now and we're stuck in it it's
not like we just all of a sudden decided
you know what today we're gonna go after
joe rogan no joe rogan did it to himself
by you know and here's the thing like if
he never brought any people on to like
spread this information around covet
this none of this [ __ ] would happen i
doubt this would have ever like no blown
up feature takes would not have posted
this video that alex jones made the only
people that would have seen this video
from alex jones are people who are
racist in the first place because they
follow alex jones let me let me play a
little bit of this [ __ ] this
chucklehead not talking here to the
mizella's brothers because what he's
accusing him of is being some part of
some conspiracy to take down joe rogan
or some [ __ ] which i'm going to go back
and play actually what might as touch
said on their [ __ ] podcast about
about the spotify uh boycott let's let's
play what this one right one plus one
two well we this is easy so far right
yeah yeah the video that alex jones made
the the patriot takes video the one that
alex jones made the the picture takes is
the headline right
yeah so actually the video that it takes
it's just the picture it takes account
right that's what we're saying
people don't preach it takes pictures
i'm just talking about like he's
literally giving away the [ __ ] thing
pager takes pager takes me like he
really practiced like he i don't know i
don't know how long he practiced
somebody shared somebody shared a tweet
in the chat last night about how
they're like uh he had tweeted i guess
from the plane i don't know i didn't
verify it but somebody tweeted about
like how they had run out of wine or
something on the plane and someone was
like he's sounding a little sloppy so
he's a little sauced yeah
well i i mean i mean he had trouble the
the word goes with his wi-fi i mean
maybe it took him a little while to get
set up
right they were streaming to his account
in their account there's a lot of trolls
in there of course i was having fun with
those [ __ ] oh yeah i was i was
dropping comments like crazy you go
watch the video i'm sure mindy's touch
still has the uh the live chat uh
available to go look at uh it's very
interesting to see how many [ __ ]
racist misogynist pigs support this guy
and everyone's like oh he's not
you gotta take it easy he's just a
comedian well look when when people like
joe rogan and portnoy are tracking
[ __ ] despicable vile pieces of [ __ ]
as their fans and defend them with
phrases and and maga and trump 2024
they're like well i'm not i'm not a i'm
not a fan of truck i know
it it's
the people okay so
which brings up another thing right like
these people that are trying to make the
argument like well he's a comedian he's
going to be edgy and he's going to be
blunt he's going to tell you how it is
here's the thing you could be those
things without saying racist things
right or or you can do those things say
racist [ __ ] and then live with the
consequences i mean right and that's
true right right and then the people are
like oh well you know he wasn't doing
stand-up it's like nope there's actually
100 right you know and it's like he said
it
on the podcast he's comfortable saying
the podcast he's comfortable saying it
in front of a crowd you know a friend a
fellow comedian said to me he said um
he's like the way that i think about
jokes is like would you ever feel
comfortable
saying that joke or whatever it was in a
room full of people that that is about
right right those are the only people in
the room would you be okay saying it
right you're willing to punch down right
are you willing to say those
disgusting gross things are you willing
to say the n word as a joke in a room
full of black people as a white person
right like are you fine doing that and
being okay like let's i you know think
of the jokes that way
if you're okay punching down this group
then you're okay saying in front of that
group while you punch down at them right
they're they're the you're using them as
a joke you know the plan of the apes
thing is gross and disgusting
you're making racist jokes right and
it's not just it's not just the n word
that he used like he's he's saying buy a
racist [ __ ] without even saying the n
word right right exactly this isn't this
isn't like just joe rogan said the n
word over and over and over again out of
context just to say well i mean there
are a few instances where he was just
trying to say it like he was right
clearly just trying to say it but he's
making racist [ __ ] trope jokes and
and and it's part of his stand-up act
for years this isn't like he just
off-handedly improv this joke and he was
writing on stage and he made it you know
he made a couple off-handed remarks when
he was writing you know they call it
writing on stage for stand-ups
and that's not what it was he was doing
this routine for years and continuing to
go to places and refine this racist
[ __ ] trope which that's fine you had
the right to do that in this country you
had the right to be racist you had the
right to be hateful you had the right to
harbor those [ __ ] feelings you had
the right to say the [ __ ] n word you
have the right but you don't get to not
live with the consequences if there are
consequences right that is how this
[ __ ] works that's how [ __ ] freedom
of speech works you have the right to
remain silent if you want to and you do
not have to say that word and not only
that you do not you do not have to tell
jokes that are [ __ ] racist and punch
down at a group of people like people of
color black people
the like you right you have the option
not to do that joe rogan chooses he
chooses not to do that and when when
[ __ ] white people especially fragile
white males out there [ __ ] defend him
because well it's his right to say it it
is his right
it is his [ __ ] right to say it but
what you don't understand about rights
and freedoms is everyone else has the
right to be [ __ ] offended and they
have the right to punish him with their
[ __ ] wallets right and they have the
right to punish spotify with their
[ __ ] wallets that's what you don't
understand is freedoms and rights extend
to everyone not just you [ __ ] white
males you [ __ ] goddamn alpha cucks it
really [ __ ] pisses me off that i have
to be [ __ ] lumped in with a group of
group of [ __ ] [ __ ] like these
idiots they really are honestly if joe
rogan if joe rogan wanted to be so
[ __ ] tough and say the n word he
would here's what his apology would have
been here's what it would have been i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm a comedian i get
to say what i want to say and if you
don't like it [ __ ] you that's what he
should have said right that's what he
should have said if he's such a [ __ ]
tough guy and he doesn't want to be
censored he hates cancer culture
pluck your head out of your [ __ ] ass
rogan right walk your [ __ ] head out
of your ass and say what you want to say
if you want to say it quit being a
little [ __ ] and when when when they
call you out and a [ __ ] a video
appears where you're being racist it
isn't some kind of hidden [ __ ] video
that someone was secretly recording you
you were saying it you were publishing
the [ __ ] you were publishing it so own
up to it just tell people i'm a comedian
i'm trying to be funny [ __ ] you i don't
care right you know what what happened
it would play well with his audience but
he's not doing that because joe rogan is
completely terrified of the consequences
here that that everyone thinks now that
he's a racist
yeah and that's what that's what you
know that's what's happening is is the
these people are looking at it and like
you know it's a catch-22 right like it's
either he's going to uh bend at the
the the will and power of spotify to say
like okay i'm so sorry you know we're
gonna pull these things
or he's gonna say no [ __ ] you i'm gonna
say what i'm gonna say now here's the
thing again you have the complete right
to say these gross disgusting things
however you do not have the right to
avoid any sort of punishment uh or
repercussions on your rent like losing
100 million dollar contract right
whether you uh lose out of your contract
you know for good faith people don't
want to subscribe don't want to watch
your shows if netflix says you know what
yeah yeah we don't want your special on
us anymore right like these are all
things that are consequences of actions
by private people or companies right the
government isn't coming in
to say
hey private company you gotta you gotta
kill it you gotta remove it you gotta
get rid of it like that's not what's
happening here again you can express
your first amendment right say what you
want to say but at the end of the day
like if you end up getting called out
for being racist
that's a consequence of your action you
made that decision right it's like
newton's law of physics right for every
uh action there's an equal and opposite
reaction so you're gonna have people
that support you and you're gonna have
people that don't [ __ ] support you
and you know you've got other comedians
who who are like putting their foot half
in and half out of the water right and
whitney cummings is an example of this
where she goes out and says like as a
comedian did she tweet that this morning
yeah that was this morning i believe
she's like we're you know we're supposed
to be dangerous and irreverent right and
sure you can yeah totally you can be
right be the jester of the court call
out the king say this [ __ ] right however
if you decide to include that type of
rhetoric and that type of the just
derogatory words or jokes in your in
your set
then just know that you're not gonna
you're gonna offend people and those
people are gonna say [ __ ] against you
right
and just know that like when it comes to
stuff like if you're punching down at a
group of people you're not doing it
right if you have to go after the cheap
jokes
to make people laugh and to and to get
the to get paid
that's you're not good you're not good
at it right like you want it and and you
know when it comes to comedy right you
want to you want to go to the to the
height of your intelligence and
unfortunately if this is the height of
his intelligence whether it's the height
of his actual height and it's short
you know that's what it is you know
here's the whitney cummings tweet right
she says comedians did not sign up to be
your hero it's uh our job to be
irreverent and dangerous to question
authority and take you through a spooky
mental haunted house so you can arrive
at your own conclusions stay focused on
the people we pay taxes to be moral
leaders that's fine sure okay great you
want to be those things you know totally
right you want to be reverent you want
to be dangerous right you want to you
want to say hey focus on the people who
are actually taking money away the you
know the one top one percent or whatever
the [ __ ] here's the thing though
this is not
it's like this is true this is like such
a half
half-assed response right like yeah well
i mean i'm not i'm not saying i'm not a
fan of whitney cummings but [ __ ] waiting
cummings here right like if you're using
this as an excuse to say like what joe
rogan did is because he's a comedian
he's being dangerous and irreverent
fine but just own up to the fact that
people aren't gonna agree with you and
own up to the fact that you can
hold someone personally accountable and
i think what's happening here is the
fact that whitney cummings is still
trying to play up to joe rogan
and
well i mean i mean whitney cummings says
is a friend of joe rogans they're
personal friends she's a yeah several
times um you know i i know i know that
they probably have a relationship um as
far as professionally and a friendship
right um because comedians hang out with
comedians that's that's how it works i
mean uh but you know but the crazy thing
is she's willing to speak out against
crystalia once everything becomes
official about the right like the gross
things that he did
but then when it comes to joe rogan now
whether she's trying to use this as a
statement because again i think it's a
half-assed statement where it's like it
could be applied to say we're comedians
we do things i'm not addressing joe
rogan specifically but this is what we
are to be as committed she's talking
about joe rogan right but on the other
end she's like oh joe i'm here for you
i'm supporting you i didn't mention your
name but i did say that we're gonna be
dangerous and what you're saying by the
n word is dangerous but it's these
people who are using joe rogan and
they're not willing to speak out against
him by saying
i'm going to or by by their actions is
i'm going to use joe rogan to to build
myself up and and climb up this ladder
of uh within the industry which is
unfortunate because joe rogan is so
[ __ ] big if you're small and you call
him out then you get attacked like even
last night i made a post about you know
joe rogan and why people are okay not
with the fact they're okay with him
being racist they're just not okay with
people calling out that he's being
racist and of course the responses i get
is i get some dumbass racist responses
in my comments where people are like oh
i hope ice comes for your corny ass like
okay
right you're an american citizen
i was born in this country i'm a citizen
of the united states i'm hispanic i'm a
latino i've got family on both sides of
the border but also when you come in
with some racist stereotypical [ __ ] and
try to say that i'm going to be deported
with ice [ __ ] you and [ __ ] everyone that
comes with you right like i don't
appreciate that [ __ ] so if you're a
comedian and you're going to say oh well
saying the n word insane you know uh
things that are derogatory against
certain groups minorities you know
people with disabilities is dangerous
and irreverent [ __ ] you and you know
just go [ __ ] yourself because i think in
a day that's a cheap that's a cop-out
right that is not addressing the
situation while also trying to address
it and it's either do it or don't do it
right and like have a position but don't
don't sit in the middle here and try to
play both sides because
it's just it's that's just not how it
goes so if you're gonna say this stuff
own up to the fact that it's like i said
it and you know what i meant it right
because i meant it as a joke and i
wanted you to laugh whether it's it's
you're trying to do something satirical
or or you're just trying to be racist i
don't know but at the end of the day
it's like you probably shouldn't be the
one saying it especially if you're a
white dude or a white woman trying to
defend a white man saying this thing
right well you know it's you know what's
funny about these comedians because we
we do satire and comedy here i i don't
actually consider myself a comedian i i
know you do and
i consider myself more commentary now i
use comedy to try to you know present
the commentary right um but when when
she says here comedians did not sign up
to be your hero well you
no hero like signs up to be a hero like
that's not how it works and and and i
want to say she's going to check that
box
we don't have a huge show here it's it's
we're gaining an audience and and i i
love that that we were able to partner
with midas you know full disclo full
disclosure for portnoy we partnered with
minus so we're part of the cabal we're
going to get called off right
absolutely i hope i wish i wish you
would come on the show whitney you are
welcome to come on the show too i will i
will have anyone that wants to come on
the show come on the show i would have
rogan alex jones [ __ ] i we a couple
weeks ago we had the former guy on in in
parody but we had him on i would have
anyone on this show and i would [ __ ]
challenge him i would eat portnoy for
[ __ ] lunch um like ben my zelis did
last night it was [ __ ] fantastic you
gotta go watch that but here's the thing
about whitney
she's saying comedians didn't sign up
here no one does and joe rogan when he's
doing his podcast isn't always a
comedian when he's talking about [ __ ]
vaccines and people dying or living with
the disease he's not a comedian you
[ __ ] need to understand this he
is he is operating in a space of
commentary not comedian comedians get up
on stage and do exaggerations and tell
jokes and if they use their comedy to
punch down that's [ __ ] gross that's
[ __ ] gross so yes comedians are
supposed to call truth to power and i
actually have a clip of a very [ __ ]
famous comedian that i would like to
play here um and you'll know why because
this isn't a new [ __ ] thing that's
the thing that really pisses me off
about this this [ __ ] you know joe
rogan i'm i'm fragile and right you know
i'm a comedian you can't hold me
accountable this isn't [ __ ] new
this is george carlin on larry king both
of these individuals are now dead
um back back in the 1980s and early 90s
there was a comedian called andrew dice
clay andrew's still around i think he
still does stand up um andrew dice clay
was actually a character that it's kind
of like the larry the cable guy you know
it really wasn't it wasn't him he was do
using exaggeration right and andrew
would punch down um as as you would
refer to it he would punch down to poor
people right he was doing bits about
this and george carlin was on larry king
i'm not sure the exact year of this clip
but he was on larry king and larry asked
about it let's hear what what's here
what carlin has to say about punching
down and specifically listen to what he
says about fragile white men i would
defend to the death his right to do
everything he does the thing that i find
unusual and it's you know it's not a
criticism so much but his targets are
underdogs and comedy traditionally has
picked on people in power people who
abuse their power women and gays and
immigrants are kind of to my way of
thinking underdogs and you know he ought
to be careful because he's jewish and a
lot of the people who want to pick on
these kind of groups the jews are on
that list a little further you've got
women gays gypsies
and suddenly you find jews and then
leandra was arrested yeah so uh you know
i mean obviously he should do what he
wants and uh why does he get away with
it do you think then he has never
laughed at jokes about this well he's
appealing i think he's appealing largely
i think his core audience are young
white males who are threatened by these
groups i think a lot of these guys
aren't sure their manhood because that's
a problem when you're going in through
adolescence you know am i really i mean
could i be i hope i'm not one of them
and the women who assert themselves and
are competent are a threat to these men
and so are immigrants in terms of jobs
and and
and so that's why we as an audience then
will laugh you say we i don't think you
mean i don't know but i think you're
collectively i think that's what what is
at the core of that experience that
takes place in these arenas there's a
certain uh
you know a sharing of anger and rage and
at these these targets and i'm sure
andrew isn't that angry at that i'm sure
he's
so that is that is a clip
uh and again i'm not sure exactly what
year that is from
but it is during this time where andrew
dice clay uh was making jokes and a lot
of people were questioning the jokes
that they were offhanded or not this
isn't [ __ ] new and george garland's
talking about fragile white men and the
reason why he's talking about fragile
white men here is because fragile white
men are are the power structure in this
country
punching punching at fragile white men
it's not punching down it's punching up
you are not oppressed you dumb
[ __ ] i'm one of them trust me i
know i'm not oppressed
you you have to [ __ ] search and
search and search for oppression you
gotta go to a burger king and [ __ ] that
you can't get a whopper because of a
choice that you made that makes you a
press get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] and and and for anyone anyone to
defend what joe rogan said and and not
only that but the way that he did his
apology because honestly i would much
rather joe
shut his [ __ ] mouth and not apologize
for what he said or come out and say
[ __ ] you because the apology that was
made is i'm sorry i got caught right
like that it's like i'm sorry right i'm
really sorry that this video circulated
throughout the internet which put me on
high right yeah and i think in addition
to that it's also the fact that we're
like yeah i'm sorry i got caught but
also i'm sorry you feel that way and and
in that way it is so dismissive of
someone's feelings right like i've
definitely you know whether it's in a
fight or you know an argument with
somebody like oh i'm sorry you feel that
way and it's like
and after the fact i feel so bad because
it totally dismisses the way that the
other person feels right and i know and
i and i've had people you know say that
i've heard it from other people about
other people you know or or something i
said or whatever
but those moments are like uh you know
where i'm like i'm sorry you feel that
way it's like so like it's a knee-jerk
reaction it's like well i feel the
certain way that i feel and you feel
certain when i feel so i'm sorry that
offends you right and at the end of the
day it's like we
it's like
you know you may feel that way but you
shouldn't completely just disregard a
group of people because they were
offended by the fact that you've said
the n word on multiple occasions
right like you can't just dismiss this
experience that a a group of
you know black people have against
having a white person say something that
has a very derogatory meaning to it
right
and and so when they see that it's like
hey dude that
kind of pisses me off like i liked you
however when you say this it really
offends me and instead of saying
i'm sorry you know what i won't say it
again i should be better that was
that was when i was like trying to you
know uh cause controversy and get known
or do this or ruffle some feathers or
whatever still not an excuse
but it's but maybe it's the truth right
and maybe it's the truth but at least if
you were to come out if you was to come
out and say that is a listen you know
what
that was dumb i shouldn't have done that
like now i'm listening to what you guys
are saying my fans and i'm trying to
make sure that i can be better as a
comedian and a commentator right and so
if he were to actually do that i think
it might have gone over better in terms
of yes it still is a terrible thing that
he did but also people could be like
okay yeah sure people make mistakes and
they can grow and they can adapt and
they can evolve as a human being and
they can get empathy and they can say
you know what that was me back then and
this is me now and it's completely
different but he didn't do that he
doubled down and he said sorry
sorry i feel that way sorry i'm not
sorry sorry i got caught i'm making this
apology so i can like i make an apology
because the videos going around about me
and i want to save face and then instead
of it he's like
it's like when someone says i think it's
the example of like yo listen like i've
got no racist bone in my body but right
right i'm not a racist but
like if there's a butt trailing at the
end of that it totally negates what you
just said it means that you are
let me let me give you a little context
because i can give you context from
white america and the perspective
because i've said the n word before i
said it a lot when i was a kid because
it was okay to say it because there
wasn't black people around and it was it
was it was easy to punch down in those
communities and it continues to be easy
to punch down in those communities
because like you said you wouldn't say
these people that say these jokes or say
the word wouldn't go in front of a
stadium of black people and say the word
into a microphone right in context or
out of context they wouldn't do it right
and i've said this on the show before
there's the thing that white people do
they do the look around do you know what
the look around is yeah you know what it
is yeah yeah before you say what you're
going to say you're going to look around
to see if there's going to be anyone
within earshot that that is going to
hear that word and be offended and
here's here's the cold hard truth that
white people don't [ __ ] know black
people are not scared of the n-word
they're not scared of it it doesn't
scare them it doesn't give them fear
that's not what it is and if you took
two seconds two [ __ ] seconds to
talk to one black person let alone maybe
a group of of of black people or people
of color in general if he took two
[ __ ] seconds to talk to him about it
and ask them why that word is the way it
is in our culture they would [ __ ]
explain it to you
they would explain it to you they would
give you the context of why that word is
the way it is why they get to you know
because that's the [ __ ] trope they
get to say it there was a lot of [ __ ]
footage of him saying that type of [ __ ]
yeah why they get to say it and we don't
type [ __ ]
they would give you the reason why
and it's it's not like there's there's
this some [ __ ] secret that they that
they talk about in private and they
won't tell individuals out there that
don't understand
why that word has the [ __ ] the
the weight that it does right because it
is just a word it's just letters it's
just a sound it is just a word but what
comes with the word is what is important
to these folks that you are targeting
with that word that is the [ __ ]
importance of it and if you pluck your
head out of your [ __ ] ass for for
more than two seconds and and maybe joe
could do this maybe he could bring on
people of color continuing on his show
and for them to explain to him into a
[ __ ] microphone why that word is
offensive and why he shouldn't say it
maybe that is a redemption that he could
make i don't know the apology is not but
but white folks out there that have your
[ __ ] headphones on that are listening
to me
they are not scared of that [ __ ] word
that does not scare them they're not
scared of it they're not scared of
racist tropes most people of color are
not scared of racist tropes that's not
what it's about to them and if you would
take us and i'm not even gonna tell you
what it is because i don't know i'm not
i'm white
go and ask people that you know why go
ask them why they will [ __ ] tell you
they're not scared to talk about it
they're not scared to tell you they're
not they won't be go ask them and so joe
rogan if you're out there you are again
um our little show here uh you are
welcome to come on the show i wouldn't
and would never be scared to go on his
show or him to come on mine oh
you think you could go on i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't i i i would if he would
invite me but he can come on here and
talk about it too but joe my suggestion
is my suggestion is is that in the next
three four five maybe six or eight
episodes you have people of color that
come on your show and you ask them why
what you said is offensive and you
[ __ ] listen right you sit there and
you [ __ ] listen because i actually
believe that joe rogan is a listener on
his show when i've listened to a show he
is a listener but a lot of times he
doesn't want to hear the truth right and
that's the problem that spotify has with
joe rogan right now is that he doesn't
want to hear the truth he doesn't want
to know what what the [ __ ] every what
the feeling is about what he's saying
and how he's saying it because it just
isn't the n word it's not just that i
mean he's getting called out on that and
and thank god for the rock dwayne
johnson to take the stance that he took
i actually think that the rock entering
the chat and me and you talked about
this rock entering the chat actually is
it has way more weight against joe rogan
and spotify than anything else that's
happened yeah
he's a big name and the thing is like
everyone else who's like again yeah when
he comes another people who are like
you like you know wishy-washy like
the rock is someone who's like listen
this is [ __ ] i'm gonna stand up
against it this is not allowed right and
he's a big name where he's got a big
voice and a powerful message and so like
especially for someone who is he's half
black right so it's like
he he is someone who this this goes
against so if he's gonna say something
to say like you know what not cool don't
do it i i distance myself from this
person that's sending a message to a lot
of other people because there's gonna be
crossover between the joe rogan crew and
the rock crew and they're going to find
themselves where they're on that venn
diagram whether they agree with joe
rogan and say you know what [ __ ] you
rock or they say oh you know what that
actually is really messed up i'm going
to side with a rock on this one
so i think that and then not only but
the last thing i want to say on this is
the fact that the people who are trying
to make this dumb excuse which andrew
yang tried to last night right and then
got called out for
is this whole like listen i know a lot
of black
friends [ __ ] peop the black friends that
work with each other right and it's like
that's we're going to go with that like
we're going to go with the whole like
you see what i tweeted him did you see
what i tweeted him
i tweeted him oh you're going to go with
the black friend [ __ ] right you are a
complete dumb [ __ ] is what and i'm not
saying my tweet caused him to delete the
tweet but almost within a couple of
minutes
i mean i tweeted that and within a
couple minutes that son of a [ __ ] was
deleted because by the time i sent it to
a few people to look at um and and a few
people seen it they were like hey he
already deleted his tweet he deleted the
swedish legislate and i'm not saying it
was but what i'm saying is i'm taking
credit i'm gonna take credit i got
andrew yang to delete his black friend
stupid [ __ ] the craziest part is the guy
goes on like two hours later and starts
the [ __ ] whole conversation up again
like andrew you [ __ ] up you deleted
the tweet right you're gonna trend for a
couple hours move the [ __ ] on you
dumbass
because the original tweet happened and
then he doubled down on it
and said well well well he said he's
still in the written tweet right he said
original tweet uh joe works with black
people right right and then and then and
the thread he was like um it it's okay
because when you work with black people
it doesn't make you a racist i know
something like that right it's like or
he's like i have no other he's like i
know black people that can speak on or
just right to the same thing which is
like i have black friends i have black
friends
you put it down and then you double down
and you got called out and you deleted
it and then i think last night i saw a
tweet that was like him asking about if
there was like a statue of limitations
for things that were said online
i don't got you a limitation what the
[ __ ] is he talking about he's basically
saying like can you hold on let me see
if i can find it uh
he said he's a dumb [ __ ] andrew yang is
um he completely is a dumb [ __ ] and and
the reason why he has appeal is because
of audiences like rogan like joe rogan
joe rogan endorsed the socialist bernie
sanders right right
and and here is andrew yang who fights
for universal income right
and and now he's defending joe rogan
because andrew yang understands that
there's crossover there right there's
bernie crossover
with rogan
and the reason why there's a lot of
crossover is because of white male
fragility
like rogan isn't a conservative rogan
isn't necessarily a fascist i don't
actually believe rogan is a fascist i
don't believe he says a lot of fascist
[ __ ] he says a lot of authoritarian [ __ ]
but i don't i don't i i don't actually
think rogan knows enough about politics
to have a [ __ ] political opinion to
be quite honest with you but but
he he [ __ ] endorsed bernie sanders he
endorsed bernie sanders full-on endorsed
him like bernie was taking pictures with
him the whole nine yards right right
i i can't imagine that that it's just
right because what yeah
it's with this timeline we live in this
fight right i know so when i had when
i've had people that on this post
yesterday that i had uh about joe rogan
and people being okay with him being
racist but not okay with people calling
out that he's racist people were like
he's not racist he's had so many like
these are the things that i heard he's
not racist because he endorsed bernie
sanders he's not racist because he had
uh many many black comedians on his
podcast he's not racist because he's
friends with dave chappelle he's not
racist because you know uh
i don't even know like something i mean
joe rogan may not be racist but he says
a lot of racists right and that's the
thing i never saw
i never said that he was a racist i said
that he was being racist right right
right and being racist through the words
that he said but obviously people when
they read that like i constructed the
tweet a certain way i'm not white people
white people who read that because let
me tell you something let me tell you
something black people and people of
color when they know that joe rogan's
saying racist [ __ ] they know that he may
not be a racist but he definitely is
saying racist ass right so when i do
this post you know i specifically wanted
not to call him a racist because you
know i think obviously everyone has
their own racist biases and things like
that and everyone is trying to hopefully
trying to better themselves uh but you
know through society and things that we
see in the media like everyone's gonna
have and make assumptions and
stereotypes and well it takes a little
bit i mean i i come from the experience
it takes a little bit i have i have a i
have a moment that i am completely
ashamed of and i'm not i'm not afraid to
talk about it because i'm com and it is
one of the most shameful things i have
ever done to another human being in my
life and i did it out of what i was
programmed to think and and
by the culture that i grew up in
and it was it's anti-gay i went to a
college party with a friend one time and
in chicago
of all places and there were there were
two guys there that were in a
relationship and and they were being
kissy kissy huggy huggy and my fragile
white male ass got really [ __ ]
butthurt about it got so upset and i i
didn't make a huge scene but i made
enough of a scene that people knew and i
am [ __ ] ashamed that i did that
[ __ ] totally ashamed of myself and
let me tell you something that event
haunts me
but i know i know the wrong that i did
and and the wrong wasn't that i made a
scene the wrong wasn't that that i i may
have said something or made someone feel
certain it's that i harbored those
[ __ ] thoughts
and by harboring those thoughts i
projected those thoughts into the world
in front of people that
that it shouldn't it shouldn't it was
disgusting and vile right right so i
changed i changed the way i thought
because i realized that what i was doing
and what i was doing wasn't making a
scene or saying racist [ __ ] into a
microphone what i would what i did was
as i ch my mindset was wrong right it
was wrong joe rogan's mindset when he's
saying the n word when he's saying these
[ __ ] jokes about planet of the apes
and how he doesn't get the sadian word
and black people do when he's doing
jokes like that his [ __ ] mindset's
wrong his aim is wrong he may not be a
racist it really [ __ ] looks like it
though but he may not be racist but he's
saying racist ass [ __ ] [ __ ] and he's
doing it intentionally especially when
he's having conversations with jordan
peterson about like the pigmentation or
the uh melanin in your skin to be like
jordan peterson let's just let's just
call this
jordan peterson is as white as my
[ __ ] shirt right now right okay that
guy's like well actually i'm tan shut
the [ __ ] up right now and joe rogan he's
like oh i don't understand why they call
him black people huh it's like trevor
noah did a good kind of position on this
uh but he this whole thing where like uh
joe rogan goes well i don't know i don't
get why they're black i mean they're
actually like brown there's like
different hues oh
my [ __ ] god do you just like i'm not
even
other people can comment on it because
obviously you know that they can do a
better job but when i saw that i was
like you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
and that's not even something that was
from long ago that was one of the more
recent podcasts that he did that had
that had blown up uh and also to bring
on jordan peterson uh just
that guy's a [ __ ] disaster
um
but
i mean well yeah and the reason why he's
a [ __ ] disaster is because i believe
jordan peterson probably is a [ __ ]
racist it's not saying racist [ __ ] he is
a [ __ ] racist because there are
racists out there and when joe rogan
does what he does when he platforms
people like that and not only when he
platforms people he plays with the idea
that he may believe that [ __ ] when he
has 11 million or 20 million however
[ __ ] however many million listened to
him what he's doing is he's platforming
those ideas and he's putting it in minds
of people who were like me
right he's programming their minds to
believe that [ __ ] and and causing these
people to do things like i did that i'm
[ __ ] totally ashamed of and this
happened i think i was probably i
probably wasn't even 21 yet when i went
to this party
and but
even even that long ago i'm still
[ __ ] ashamed the way i acted and it
wasn't because of what i said it was
because of what i harbored inside of me
and i know that it was [ __ ] wrong and
the reason why i harbored it the reason
why white people in this country harbor
that [ __ ] they aren't [ __ ] born
racist white people aren't born bigots
they're not they're [ __ ] taught that
[ __ ] yeah the culture embeds it into
their [ __ ] brains i mean look at look
at children right like they aren't they
don't they don't know the difference of
the skit like that isn't something where
they go like you look different so
you're weird right like they know the
difference they know that black is
beautiful they know that there's white
they know that they're hispanic but they
learn that that's right um like it's
it's but they learn the hatred they
learn the hatred they learn the hatred
through their culture and their society
right trust me 100
when joe rogan is standing on stage
talking about how or into a microphone
talking about how he went to a movie the
planet of the apes and when he got out
he thought he was in africa that's what
he's doing
that's what the [ __ ] he's doing he is
playing to the culture of white america
that is racist he's playing and it's not
just jokes he's making against black
people like he's made right tons of
jokes against the mexican community as
well right like he had a joke about he
was he stumbled out uh out of his uh
uh
he made some joke hold on let me see if
i can find it well let me be clear why
you're looking for that joe rogan has
the absolute right to make these jokes
right and say him into microphones i'm
not saying just like george carlin said
i would defend to the death his right to
say these things and honestly i hope
more races say this [ __ ] they say it out
loud until microphone because then we
know who the [ __ ] they are we know who
joe rogan is we know who he is we know
he is and yes do we want people to stop
listening to him absolutely
absolutely so this is a tweet that joe
rogan sent from 2009 right you know be
an edgy comedian
and it's like
let me pull this up here yeah
you want to read it yeah the tacos i ate
at lax this morning just came stumbling
out of my ass like illegals in a mexican
clown car pulled over by immigration
like
you know obviously obviously he's making
a joke here right right he's like
what he's doing is he's punching down
right
and he's making and he's saying like oh
all the legals are coming like are
packing into these cars you know and
whether immigration because immigration
is always a hot topic right but whether
this was like a hot topic you know
moment for immigration he was like oh
i'm gonna double down on immigration and
make a joke about it like the fact is
it's not a good joke it's dumb and also
it plays into the stereotype that
mexicans are like are piling in whether
it's where they're living or whether
they're driving or they're trying to
illegally across like cross the border
and with a coyote and a you know what a
really good comedian could do you know
what a really good comedian could do
they could go to lax and eat tacos and
have have the shits and they could
actually make a joke about it without
being [ __ ] racist like exactly yeah
they could they could even they could
even talk about
mexican people in the tweet in the joke
they could even do that they could talk
about mexican people in the joke and not
be racist like it is a thing that you
can do you choose your words yep and and
joe rogan chose his words here on this
tweet so that way what what's funny
about this is that this is 2009. if you
look at it it's got 69 likes what is
this this guy's account so i get more
than 69 likes on when i talk about the
you know michael flynn smelling like a
turd and you know i called it michael
flinders i get more like come on joe
right come on joe but the point is the
point is is that you can eat tacos at
lax you can get the shits
and and you can it can be crazy and it
hurt you badly or whatever and you can
make jokes you can even say the word
mexican in the joke without being racist
you can do those things you can but he
chose not to
and for anyone to be like oh well you
can't make this
howard stearns racist yeah howard stern
has chosen a few times throughout his
career to be racist and we should call
him out on it the same way as the young
turks and on and on and on and on yeah
if they plan on being racist and they're
going to use
racism to punch down at people whether
it be through comedy or commentary
whatever they have the right to do it
but we actually have the right to say
hey we'll call you out on it that's
that's what happens that's what happens
you don't get to live without the
consequences you have the freedom of
speech but not the freedom to not suffer
consequences for that speech exactly
whoa that was a soapbox we're we're 54
minutes into the second hour i know you
had to jump out a little early
are you having to go here yeah yeah i do
i got it okay well well um thanks for
the rant uh
stick around audience we'll we'll be
right back
after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopers mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your drew today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv
slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking with us
gabe had to run
there at the very end
um i think it was a fantastic
fantastic discussion that we had we
definitely wanted to go through uh the
joe rogan stuff and i know i know um you
know he's he's gotten a lot of heat uh
about the the misinformation on the
covid which is where the conversation
started and where the boycott of of
spotify started and again i i i'm not i
i'm not saying joe rogan shouldn't be
able to talk into a microphone now
rather spotify keeps his contract
tonight well that's [ __ ] up to them
that's up to them um
but the racism thing
where the conversation we talked about
this with rachel bitcoffer earlier
this whole thing is turned on its head
on joe rogan here um the whole [ __ ]
thing is turned up on its head now
because it's not about the
misinformation anymore it's about
it's about joe rogan being held
accountable for the [ __ ] he says into a
microphone and really when when dwayne
johnson the rock uh entered the
conversation is where that that
that accountability shifted because joe
rogan understood the ramifications of
the rock dwayne johnson um making the
statement that he made and not defending
him and i think everyone else understood
the ramifications of the rock doing that
i'm not saying the rock is all powerful
but in that universe in the uni in the
universe of entertainment and the
universe
of hollywood and the universe of
speaking into microphones the rock has
one of the biggest [ __ ] microphones
there is uh joe rogan has a huge
microphone but it's nowhere near as big
as the rocks and i think that is what
joe rogan understood and he made the
apology he stumbled he [ __ ] it up um
he completely he completely
completely ate the [ __ ] sandwich on this
one and he's gonna continue to eat the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] sandwich on this one and for anyone
to blame it to blame it on anyone
specific whether it be a group of
brothers who have a super pac
um you guys got to go watch the [ __ ]
portnoy
the debate um when ben meizelus here's
what happens i'll just give you a little
synopsis uh so you can go over there and
and look at it number one
portnoy dude it would have took you two
[ __ ] seconds two seconds to google
who ben my zealous was and understand
that the dude is a [ __ ] attorney and
not just an attorney a really [ __ ]
good one colin kaepernick wouldn't
[ __ ] hire some
schmuck okay
ben my zealous goes through you can see
it happening in real time like this goof
this goof port no i didn't even see it
coming
like he's accusing uh midas touch of
being patriotics and not only that he's
accusing them of being this this uh um
resist programming which who gives a
[ __ ] if they're part of resist
programming who gives a [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] he claimed oh because they follow
you and you follow them on twitter you
must be them he really is a dumb [ __ ]
this portnoy and again i would welcome
this dumb [ __ ] on my show because i
would eat him for [ __ ] lunch him and
his audience hear me i would [ __ ]
destroy him on this show especially on
this [ __ ] topic
but the best part is
is you know he's going on and on and on
on and on and on about how
how midas touch his patriot takes and
might as touches resist programming and
all his [ __ ]
and then we get down to the bar spools
barstool sports and ben asked him about
a show that they had barstool sports
that had the n-word in the title i think
that's the case
and portnoy says well there was three
black people hosting that
did my zealots ask well do they work at
your the organization anymore does the
show exist he's like no the show doesn't
exist they don't work at the
organization anymore and they had they
had a feud between them about the name
of the show
so ben's like well wait a second so if
you're if you had this show on the air
and these people get a disagreement and
then they took it off aren't doesn't
that mean that you fully endorse and
that you fully back the show in the name
of the show in the name and you could
you could tell that this goof didn't see
it coming
but ben my zealous the attorney that he
is turns the argument that portnoy was
trying to make totally turns it around
on him and slam dunks on him of course
portney portnoy realizes it during the
time that
ben my zealous is dunking on him
and realizes he [ __ ] up and then he
just goes back to as you seen earlier
just repeating the words patriot takes
patriot takes patriot takes patriot
takes patriot takes he continues to
repeat that word and i think their
strategy was is just just to say patriot
takes the whole time like that seemed
like his strategy
um that he was just gonna say patriot
takes and and and act like they own
resist programming which i don't
understand what the [ __ ] big deal is
about resist programming these twitter
accounts like who gives a [ __ ] like you
know this is real life [ __ ] we're
talking about here where joe rogan is
talking into microphones offending
people going in front of crowds and
telling racist [ __ ] jokes like in
real life he's doing this [ __ ]
not not not someone reporting it on a
[ __ ] twitter thread you dumb
[ __ ]
and the best part is the best part is
is ben calls him out calls him out on on
retweeting the vocal thread
like he's like oh yeah you you patriot
takes patriot takes picture takes you
amplify patriot takes and like it's the
worst thing in the world you're part of
the blood sucking cabal or some i don't
know some [ __ ]
and then and then the myself brothers
are like yeah but you're retweeting
local like so does that mean you're
local does that mean you're it's [ __ ]
fantastic go over and watch that on
youtube just go to the mighty dutch
youtube channel you can watch the the
portnoy debate if you want to call it
that it isn't much of a debate um it's
really one-sided and that portland gets
his [ __ ] ass handed to him uh portnoy
you really should stick to bar stool
sports type [ __ ] you really should you
shouldn't really weigh in on political
commentary you're a [ __ ] dumbass and
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
uh
so i appreciate you guys joining us
today
rachel's conversation was fantastic i'll
cut rachel's conversation out post it on
youtube so you guys can uh see that so
go subscribe to the youtube channel if
you're here on youtube now and you're
not subscribed do that um i i wanna i
wanna pitch the uh
uh the the interview we had last week
with tasha and dakota adams um the midas
touch partner with us on the
distribution of that they actually and
we're part of the cabal we're part of
the cabal um
they partnered with us on the
distribution of that interview because
we wanted as many people that could put
their eyeballs on it to see that to see
that interview and you guys did you
watched it they posted a clip about the
eyeball and it went big we're probably
going to try to post some more clips
about that interview this week so go to
the the youtube channel and watch the
full interview um it's over there so
subscribe to the youtube channel also
now bone end of the week we'll have that
pull up probably today or tomorrow so
follow at tony michael's pod follow me
and gabe at the tony michaels and that i
am gabe sanchez and uh go vote for
bonehead of the week because we'll do
that on friday
there's going to be plenty of [ __ ]
boneheads plenty of [ __ ] boneheads to
choose from i'm sure we won't have a a
shortage here and you know the supply
chain of boneheads is [ __ ] open
in this country join us tomorrow noon
eastern 11 central like we do every day
we're going to do the shitless roundup
tomorrow we didn't do a lot of [ __ ] list
roundup today
because we had rachel and we really
wanted to get to this joe rogan uh midas
touch cabal how they're orchestrating
the fall of joe rogan i think it's funny
that uh people think the most important
thing that the midas
the mizellas brothers at midas touch are
doing is sitting around trying to figure
out how to take down joe rogan get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] you
people are god damn you really do think
of yourselves as super [ __ ] important
don't you get out of here with that [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here and then and
and just go watch the interview because
also also they school portnoy on what a
[ __ ] p.o box is
so until tomorrow until tomorrow
noon easter 11 central right here on
youtube twitter twitch surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking